The elusive ‘theory of everything’.
A theory that could resolve the most fundamental
roadblock in our understanding of how the
universe behaves... and tie everything neatly
up with string....
It’s been 50 years since string theory was
first proposed, and new work call into question
not only essential parts of the theory itself,
but also our working understanding of the
universe.
Let’s start at the beginning.
We have two primary ways to describe how all
the ‘stuff’ in our universe behaves: one
big and one small.
The first is Einstein's theory of general
relativity, which tells us how gravity interacts
with space and time to form the world around
us.
That’s the big.
Then there’s the small: the Standard Model,
which works on the quantum level.
This says that all matter is made up of building
blocks called elementary particles*.
You can break us down into molecules, then
into atoms, then into the subatomic particles
like electrons, neutrons, and protons.
Smaller still are those elementary particles,
divided into two broad categories, quarks
and leptons, of which there are different
kinds.
Groovy.
The standard model works mathematically in
most cases, but it only incorporates three
of the four fundamental forces of our universe.
There’s the strong, the weak , and the electromagnetic
forces.
And then...there’s gravity.
Gravity is the odd one out, the ugly duckling
of the Standard Model, because it doesn’t
fit.
Each of the other three forces has a carrier
particle--photons carry the electromagnetic
force, gluons carry the strong force, and
W and Z bosons carry the weak force.
But we haven’t discovered a carrier particle
for gravity, which we would call the graviton...
if we could find it.
This means the mathematical calculations of
the Standard Model and those that underpin
Einstein’s theory of general relativity
don’t match up with each other.
If we could find some way that they could
work together, we’d have a theory of...everything.
It’s this misalignment--and desire for unity--that
gave birth to string theory.
So how does string theory tie our ideas of
the universe together?
Instead of picturing elementary particles
as distinct points, string theory posits that
all elementary particles can be pictured more
like a vibrating string.
Each particle is technically the same string,
it’s just vibrating in a different way,
the way that a string on a musical instrument
can play different notes ...including that
elusive note, gravity.
Ok that sounds pretty tempting.
Of course, there are issues.
The level on which we would be able to observe
strings vibrating is wayyyy outside our current
capabilities.
Famous string theorist Brian Greene says we’d
need to build a particle collider the size
of the galaxy to be able to directly observe
strings in action.
Since observation is off the table, how about
math?
Well, the math tells us something pretty freaky.
The equations that make string theory work
require that the universe has at least ten
dimensions.
We’re only able to observe four of these--the
three dimensions of space with time as a commonly
proposed 4th dimension.
The extra dimensions required by string theory
is where parallel universes start to come
into play.
Since strings are so small, the math tells
us that they would not just be vibrating in
the large dimensions we know of, but in other
tiny dimensions too.
If we know the shape of those tiny dimensions,
we might be able to predict and then observe
properties of elementary particles--like their
charge or spin--that would be attributed to
those extra dimensions.
Which would mean we’re seeing evidence of
the other dimensions!!
But the problem with that is that once scientists
tried plugging in different potential shapes
for these extra dimensions, they found that
most of them worked.
The more they tried, the more of them fit,
which meant that they had wayyyyy too many
possibilities to consider and they lost hope
that finding out the shape of the dimensions
could help us observe their existence.
Until, someone proposed that perhaps there
wasn’t just one right shape for each of
the extra dimensions--but they’re all right
in each of their own universes.
Meaning there are OTHER UNIVERSES.
Potentially over 10^500 others, each ever-so-slightly
different from our own.
And yeah, I’m still talking about theoretical
physics, not science fiction, although it’s
a pretty thin line if you asked me.
That’s where we all were up until a few
weeks ago, when controversial new mathematical
papers may have blown all of this apart.
And this big upset involves dark energy.
We think we’ve observed that our universe
is slowly expanding.
Our explanation for this is...dark energy.
And there are lots of theories about what
it is and how it behaves to make the universe
expand, but we don’t have anything nailed
down on that front yet.
These recent papers provide new evidence that
the math of string theory may actually prohibit
the existence of alternate universes in which
dark energy is stable.
Which means one of a couple of things: either
string theory is wrong.
Or we’re wrong about our universe.
Maybe it didn’t explode in a Big Bang, it’s
not expanding, and it will eventually contract
in what some physicists call a ‘Big Crunch’.
Or maybe there’s an entirely new way of
fitting the existence of dark energy into
our string theory calculations that no one
has tried yet.
String theorists are divided about these new
claims.
Many are not at all convinced of the papers’
claims and think the existing theories work
just fine.
So while there are no hard answers, this latest
work has sparked a renewed urgency to understand
dark energy, how it behaves and how it might
inform our theories about the behavior of
our universe and the potential existence of
others.
Still with us?
We know string theory often presents more
questions than answers, but we want you to
keep untangling the universe with us, so subscribe
to Seeker for more videos to come on topics
like this and let us know what you want to
talk about.
And check out this video here on quantum retrocausality.
Thanks for watching, I'm Maren.